hey guys been editing here for the while
Gary and I were talking and we figured
we'd try something different
um yeah here we go
what if I told you this was last Monday
morning in her life
[Music]
how's it feel not some shoulders so see
this thing in the back right here this
is going right into the back of his
scapular stabilizers they don't want
this thing they want this [ __ ] hustle
that make something happen three hours
of sleep they go work out punch and
that's an 87 hours they got some sleep
in Seattle
I got some sleep in Seattle
the other way so uh early morning here
in Seattle have to go pitch this kid or
in the final two it's exciting you know
selling baseball cards and athletes on
cardboard and now trying to sell them to
work with me and then do baseball card
in football card deals so really amazing
you never know what we're like it's
gonna take you super proud of AJ and
Brian and Luke at Vayner sports we're
having an incredible first year
obviously you guys have seen the Jalen
reeves-maybin Alvin Kamara John toad
signings these are the second round pick
tight caliber guys so it's a big first
year coming out the gate exciting to
document this journey when in three or
four years we'll be looking back as one
of the top sports agents in the world
look at these early days I wish we had
this film on vaynermedia one of a six of
us in a conference room starting the
company that would be a real blast so
gonna go in there show them the value
like every business in my life how do we
disproportionately bring value to the
other side of the table right and so in
the wine world it was better wine than
people were buying elsewhere at better
prices and
and now today it's showing these kids
that we can help them on the field off
the field and being a man after football
so excited about it we'll see rappers
just sit here landed reading the
comments of episode 121 and 120 of
dailyvee just realizing that I always
talk about comments being my oxygen and
as much as I love the love and the
admiration and the dabs which are
incredible thank you so much guys it's
incredible how much I get value out of
the insight if you believe the comments
on episode 2 right there were people
that basically said things like I've
been watching you for three years
healing you for three years I didn't get
how hard you actually one more time
yeah it's gonna allow me to give away an
enormous amount of freedom but where as
I could not do this yeah charge every
do-nothing people of tomorrow I announce
I am no longer putting out contacts I am
creating the Gary Vaynerchuk school
mastermind of marketing and it is five
thousand dollars a month just get what
you've been getting do you know how much
money I would make tens of millions of
dollars
and you know you always have those
people that want to give your feedback
critical feedback just for doing it as
an outlier it's not what I'm talking
about because I taste that energy I
promise
talking about the people that are just
really giving insights to what they're
being affected by what they're seeing
what editing they like which seems they
enjoy what they're learning from the
most it's all about this I'm so known
for this but it's all about this this
[ __ ] thing this because the work
I put into consuming you guys not other
videos or other people but you the end
user
that's the secret that people haven't
arrived yet
the reason I don't consume anybody
else's stuff the reason I don't consume
historical things the reason I don't
consume anything else but you is cuz
[Music]
I paint the fun the really cool thing
about creating content for anxiety who's
that
thank you you too you guys can enjoy all
the content read your comment
[Music]
American yeah we want your through back
we we love your feedback
yeah weird for an airport a lot of
people to have the review now on the
airplane
I really come then Gary where AM L
you're the editing in the room
[Music]